from a hidden ghost ship to a hulking
great Dancing Zombie here are 20 video
game Easter eggs that will make you say
what the [__] the operators in Rainbow
Six Siege may be a force to be reckoned
with but they also have an artistic side
too if you see a block of marble in game
give it a Quick Melee and you will
create a totally accurate tachanka
statue looking good my guy but that has
nothing on Hitman the game series packed
with ridiculous Easter eggs on this
island paradise here Agent 47 can find
and destroy 14 golden skulls after
hitting every single one of them a
mysterious Ghost Ship appears on the
waves outside never to be seen again
wait I can do better in the second Goat
Simulator game which is obviously called
Goat Simulator 3 you can find this
indestructible Rock should you bleat at
it long enough a Divine holy spirit will
hear your please and move that Boulder
for you inside is a cave with bread fish
water and wine and look who's having a
nap it's Jesus Christ by resurrecting
him you can play as disco Jesus which
gets even weirder when he
far because he's still a goat but
speaking of the undead Call of Duty Cold
War Zombies has an amazing Easter egg by
finding and shooting these orbs
eventually this will happen a zombie
coffin dance party weird this is a call
back to a viral video of Paul bearers
dancing in Ghana the internet has opened
up the world so much another video game
with impressive details and downright
weird Easter eggs is Star Wars Jedi
Fallen order an amazing detail first can
be heard when attempting to open the
first locked door in the game 66 times
eventually you'll hear this
60s
brilliant right well there's also
strange Easter eggs in here like the
tomb of zepho by moving one of the orbs
you'll unlock a hidden area it's
difficult to make the jump but once you
arrive to this place here you'll see
characters from the Star Wars franchise
the thing is they're all terribly made
with low poly versions I I think that's
supposed to be Yoda this place is cursed
Gears of War has a real WTF Easter egg
and it's all about beards on the
prologue Mission by shadowing Dom for
the entire encounter this will happen
every character from now on has a beard
and I mean everyone damn she looks good
A shark yeah not weird enough for you
what about this in alien colonial
Marines it's a tense survival team
shooter with a tasty Secret at this
section of the game look across the
cavern and you'll see a box of donuts
shooting that box does this a freaking
giant donut rolls down and crushes your
enemies just like in the movies right
just cause is another series with insane
Easter eggs here are two that are weapon
related in the Farmland it's possible to
spot this weapon on the ground using it
may shock you every NPC you hit with
this thing turns into a cow making some
weird and wonderful sights and there's
another pistol named the DK pistol you
know what it's gonna do big heads for
everyone you shoot shoot them too much
and they'll eventually float off into
space this must be a homage to the
Donkey Kong mode of GoldenEye on the N64
amazing another game that changes your
appearance is Fall Guys and the Among Us
skins in particular there is a tiny
chance that any of these skins will
change before the round starts the red
and purple variants can become imposters
complete with a smile only a mother
could love and the orange skin on the
other hand can be transformed into a
fallen crewmate which is freaky as heck
to see running around have you seen this
room in Hogwarts Legacy filled with
stone statues it suddenly becomes
apparent to what has happened here look
at the painting and the Gorgon depicted
will turn you into stone not only that
the guy in the painting will also be
turned to Granite too a brilliant Easter
egg can be found in Dying Light Up on
the Rooftops by searching for this very
specific chimney stack you'll find a
green pipe inside it just like those
found in Mary video games by jumping
through it you'll be taken to a 3D
Recreation of world one one of Super
Mario Bros complete with zombies in
Goomba cosplay they're having a good day
over to Modern Warfare 2 now and a
mission in which we are weaponless and
must run for our life players wondered
what would happen if you clicked the
inspect button without a weapon in hand
well it turns out your character plays a
game of Rock Paper Scissors by
themselves whilst being hunted down in
Brazil so weird some Easter eggs are all
about listening take this one from
Spider-Man he enjoys talking to himself
listen to what Peter says here not good
can't have people taking pictures of my
three chest hairs three chest hairs he's
joking right well thanks to photo mode
we can check and he's telling the truth
Spider-Man really does only have three
chest hairs what a hero another
PlayStation exclusive has an Easter egg
weapon the Rhino 8 in Ratchet and Clank
Rift apart summons a random item from
Another Universe and lets you drop it on
your enemy's heads these can include
items from other PlayStation games
there's a thunder jaw and other Dinobots
from Horizon Jack and Daxter can rock up
randomly and in some very rare instances
Sly Cooper and his van will show up some
Easter eggs are all about Throwing Shade
to other games like The Witcher and
Assassin's Creed we all know about how
Assassin's Creed lets us jump from high
buildings into bales of hay and totally
come out unscathed well in the witches
World things don't always go to plan
guess they'll never learn geralt is a
Savage another shade throwing Easter egg
can be found right in front of our nose
in Lego Star Wars the Skywalker Saga all
the arabesh text is fully translatable
into English most are respectable but
summer hunt Captain phasma's translates
to Chrome Dome let's draw Chrome Dome
and Count Dooku's reads never loses his
head and we all know how that went for
him in the movies do it oh on General
Grievous reads more Sabers than since
doubling down on how stupid he is and
that multi lightsaber meme I'm sure
you've seen
an unexplained Easter egg in Hunt
Showdown can be found in the shallow
Waters at the edge of this map there are
poorly made mannequins here badly
recreating that scene from the Titanic
movie
right I have no idea why but they do
look like they're having fun
Far Cry 3 has a pun based Easter egg
swimming the ocean long enough and
you'll find this guy he's not feeling
well and he's leaning over a toilet
underwater are you ready for the joke
here's the pun you ready he's seasick
okay you're you're not laughing a truly
bizarre Easter egg can be found in Dying
Light too yes it's a Zombie Survival
game but by finding the local fiver side
football pitch and scoring half a dozen
goals you'll unlock a weapon but don't
stop scoring keep going and you'll
eventually power up this goal so much
that's a hulking great zombie will
arrive and do a little dance
[Music]
things get weirder because upon beating
him you'll unlock a football blueprint
to take those soccer balls everywhere
with you
and the greatest WTF Easter egg in
gaming history has to be this one from
Hitman Absolution to get information out
of our Target we have him dig a grave in
the desert after receiving the info we
need 47 gives us a chance to just walk
away leave him alone but if we decide to
shoot the circling vultures instead
something weird happens
yep you aren't seeing things that really
was an ice cream van speeding through
the desert and eating our Target an
impossible distance you should totally
subscribe now I'm Adam you're awesome
I'll see you next time